joignable depuis un lieu tenu secret
chez ses alliés en arabie saoudite
le premier ministre du liban saad hariri
a choqué son peuple et le reste de la
planète samedi dernier en annonçant sa
démission accusant du même coup le
hezbollah et ses parrains iraniens de
vouloir l'assassiner partout devant
s'installent ils sèment la discorde la
dévastation et la destruction at il dit
ce qui démontrait par son ingérence dans
les affaires internes des pays arabes
derrien nouveau l'arabie saoudite et
l'iran s'accusent mutuellement de
vouloir imposer leur volonté dans la
région répand dans l'instabilité à tout
vent depuis longtemps la démission
surprise de saad hariri à la tête d'un
gouvernement de compromis entre les deux
principaux courants n'est rien d'autre
que le coup de semonce de l'ouverture du
front libanais dans cette guerre froide
entre les deux puissances sunnites et
chiites selon plusieurs observateurs
comme si c'était une déclaration de
guerre entre guillemets
c'était une façon de dire fini le
compromis qu'on a fait et qui m'a amené
premier ministre et a amené le président
à aoun en tant que président on est dans
une phase 2 de guerre froide déclaré par
l'arabie saudite contre l'iran et sa
politique régionale face à l'absence
prolongée de celui dont tout le monde
attend le retour au liban pour envisager
l'avenir politique du pays
les rumeurs sur son sort s'intensifie la
nuit dernière l'avion privé de saad
hariri s'est posé à l'aéroport
international de beyrouth qui porte le
nom de son père assassiné
mais le principal intéressé n'était pas
à bord on peut dire que le premier
ministre saad hariri est arrêté par
l'arabie saoudite accuse-t-il que les
autorités saoudiennes le laisse pas
rentrer au liban
c'est une agression contre la
souveraineté du liban et contre le
premier ministre hariri le royaume et
son jeune prince ambitieux joue un jeu
dangereux
pour l'analyste michel nadeau fall
appelé
fraction de la population libanaise à se
rebeller contre une autre action ça ça
nous amène à un scénario de chaos et
s'en sert pas les intérêts les intérêts
profonds de ce pays et l'intérêt des
libanais qui personne ne se presse de
demander l'avis pendant que se joue ce
grand jeu dans la région ils n'ont pas
été appelés aux urnes depuis 8 ans 8 ans
pendant lesquels ils ont tant duré deux
ans en président et plusieurs mois sans
premier ministre voilà aujourd'hui les
libanais plongée de nouveau dans
l'incertitude ce n'est pas tant le
retour des armes que craint la rue mais
plutôt de voir l'économie du petit pays
asphyxié sous le poids de la colère des
deux grandes puissances rivales ici
marie-eve bédard radio-canada beyrouth